si tu perds away confessé le nombre de
partenaires sexuels que vous avez un
petit peu joué à la pub je peux vous
dire que c'est quelqu'un sait quelque
chose il faut pas le faire chier le
philippe katerine selon philippe on va
faire un petit jeu ya quatre ballons on
va faire ce qu'on appelle un basket
confession c'est à dire que on va devoir
mettre le ballon dans le panier
oui si on ne met pas tous les deux on
doit faire une confession la première
confession c'est si tu devais coucher
avec quelqu'un du métier du même sexe ce
serait qui si tu le mets valoir des gens
décédés
oui bien sûr je pense à isabelle saporta
alors je te le dis donc si tu le mets
c'est bon pour toi t'as pas à donner ta
compassion cas d'accord si tu ne le met
pas bien sûr tu dois donner ta
confession ces essais par hape ombre si
on ne met pas tous les deux on doit lire
tous les d'accord
attention des gens de même sexe puisque
tu veux commencer oui si tu veux ces
particules ce ballon rond que tu veux
ton ballon et tu t'entraînes est que
celui-là n'entend pas mieux que sur les
ballons jaunes moi c'est pas trop mon
affaire allez vas-y fais comme tu vois
ça fait beaucoup de bruit quand vous
faites bien attention vallée philippe
alors pas surpayer pas tension
tension fait lâche il va devoir faire sa
confession c'est sûr commence au basket
à temps ouais ouais pratique
pierrick mary quant au taux de 3 euros
de droits de je dois faire ma confession
aussi donc si tu devais coucher avec une
personne de même sexe du métier ce
serait qui a du métier
oui bien qu'on exclut les du même sexe
des hommes politiques si tu peux aussi
en politique tu peux aussi basique pas
de quelqu'un peut être pas le même
métier quand quelqu'un de connu
quelqu'un de connu je dirais peut-être
mais c'est pour ça que je pensais à
quelqu'un de confortables et moi l'un
d'eux jean raymond barre ou raymond
barre à wimille et non t'as pas quelque
chose dont moi même jamais droit aux
gens des cités oui oui mais oui mais
confortable à quelqu'un de vivant dans
le même registre dans philippe seguin
décédé
moi en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que
ce n'est pas benjamin griveaux d'acier
sur moi ça serait castaldi bardon a
serré le jeu c'est que je sens
littéraire puis les tables rcs la
castagne en plus je laissais mon ami
c'est mon frère
ça fait peur mais j'ai très content
parce que c'est qu'il devra vous allez
dormir ensemble ouais ouais bah bien sur
wii en temps mais en cuir héros et toi
philippe avec ses hauts doubiens qui gît
bernet away ça va faire plaisir à pas
tout ça et tu vas prendre deux semaines
le plateau attention philippe enfers
d'un petit deuxième ballon confession
pas dit quand tu joues tu parles je ne
sens rien pour toi
[Musique]
et
allez voter du poète un jeu dire ça va
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon tu n'auras pas trop pc il
fallait lire le dernier sms que tu avais
reçu tétreault qui ma mère à travers bon
ben ça va ça va très vite dit voilà je
veux dire le dernier sms que j'ai reçu
c'est valérie benaïm je crois que c'est
dépêche toi connard on va être à
l'antenne
je crois que c'est ça le haut niveau
mais je crois que c'est ça non annoncée
à gaza où l'on les deux enquêtes du
début dans l'ordre que tu veux jean
michel est quelqu'un d'autre c'est pas
le grand amour c'est pour l'émission de
ce soir c'est pour philippe katerine
bravo tu vas faire en dernier oui si tu
veut évasif alors je vais j'ai coché une
dernière confession t'assure dernières
confessions là si tu perds away confessé
le nombre de partenaires sexuels que
vous avez eue hollande attention à l'est
être des gens de basket dix ans de
basket oh mon dieu non non non non
malheureusement c'est non et quand c'est
non c'est non
bajeux turin alors vas-y pipe
tu vas me le dire en partant on sait sur
les doigts d'une main trois jours c'est
vrai c'est vrai tu as connu ta femme à
quel âge on marche un peu bas merci les
pommes bien au maroc c'est quoi comme un
autre les doigts des mains avec son
doigt team sebah sur les doigts d'une
main bah moi bah moi tu me suis dit
c'est sur les doigts des pieds non sur
les orteils en fait une quinzaine en
quinzaine
c'est vrai philippe et si vous avez de
philippe est très costaud
alain il est touché un peu là les
épaules c'est quelque chose et bâti à il
est bâti et il est bâti philippe
katerine est avec nous allez le voir en
concert fille
[Musique]